>>D.C. office.
My primary responsibility is working on issues
of free expression,
which is one of the reasons I'm out on campus
today.
We have gathered together a group of the world's
leading experts on
circumvention technology,
and helping people to express themselves and
access information around the world.
And that's what we're going to be talking
about today.
I'll skip the long and boring lecture about
why free expression is
important to our company.
It's something that I think everybody here
shares as a principle and as
a goal.
And despite its complexity, it's something
that we work for every day.
Instead, I'm going to get right to our guest
who knows more about this
world than so many people out there and is
a real star of the field.
Professor Ron Deibert is Associate Professor
of Political Science and
Director of the Citizen Lab at the Munk Center
for International
Studies at the University of Toronto.
There are other people from the Citizen Lab
with us today as well.
It's an interdisciplinary -- I can say that
three times quickly --
research and development hothouse that works
at the intersection of the
Internet global security and human rights.
The initiative is really known for combining
the discipline of
technology with the goals and the principles
of trying to help people
not only undertake research and engage in
advanced development of
tools,
but also in helping people who otherwise would
have their voices stilled around the world.
Ron is also co-founder and Principal Investigator
of what's called the
OpenNet Initiative,
which is a research and advocacy project that
examines Internet censorship and surveillance
worldwide.
I recommend them very highly if you're interested
in what is being
censored where in the world.
They do a brilliant map that shows the difference
between political and
cultural, and the overlapping areas of censorship
around the world.
In 2002, he was awarded the University of
Toronto's Outstanding
Teaching Award,
and the Northrop Frye Distinguished Teaching
and Research Award,
and was a Ford Foundation Research Scholar
of Information Communication Technologies
from 2002 to 2004.
In the amusing category, he was named to the
Maclean's magazine honor
roll as one of 39 Canadians to have helped
make the world a better
place in 2006.
And, get this, to Esquire magazine's Best
and Brightest list in the
year 2007.
Without further ado, Ron Deibert, thank you
very much for being with
us.
[APPLAUSE]
RON DEIBERT: Thank you very much.
Thank you very much, Bob, and to Google for
hosting us here.
It's really a great opportunity to bring together
a lot of people who
have been working on this over the years.
And it's also great to see Citizen Lab alumnus
Michelle LaVeck in the
back of the room here at Google.
So a great time all-around.
As we gather here, I just want to begin my
presentation several
thousands of miles away.
Events are unfolding in Iran that really have
relevance to our
workshop.
An election is occurring and a social movement
is again mobilizing on
the streets of Iranian cities,
and connecting through networks of support
to cities across Europe and North America.
In Toronto, a very dynamic group of Iranians
have banded together in
support of activists on the ground.
And this is probably happening in cities here
in California as well.
Now the role of technology in affairs such
as these is often
overstated.
The battle is about much more than the latest
social networking tool.
No matter what label is assigned to the latest
revolution, but it
should not be underestimated, either.
Cyberspace is the domain through which the
contests of ideas takes
place today.
And is heavily contested domain by parties
on all sides of this
conflict.
It is widely known that demonstrators can
achieve wider support and
publicity through the use of cyberspace and
mobile technologies.
But the Iranian authorities are taking active
countermeasures aimed at
controlling the spaces for online resistance
and dissent.
And not just by censoring access to web sites.
They're employing more offensive actions as
well.
The Internet has slowed down in many cities
across Iran.
And there have been periods where it's not
accessible at all.
It has essentially ground to a halt similar
to what happened in
previous periods and places like Burma.
The AFP is quoting technicians as saying that
they have been ordered to
restrict Internet service in this way rather
than being some kind of
technical problem.
SMS messaging and mobile phone communications
have also been suspended
and jammed.
And cyber-organizers, dissidents, and activists
have been targeted and
arrested, not just inside the country but
outside as well.
And this is interesting that there are reports
of Iranian authorities
monitoring social networking platforms, identifying
people in Canada,
United States, and Europe and harassing them,
threatening their family members who still
live in Iran.
And of course circumvention technology, the
topic of the discussion
here today, are actively being deployed in
this, in this conflict.
In our case, with Psiphon's right-to-know
nodes are being mobilized.
And we have lots of interesting stories to
tell about our experiences
there.
And we're eager to hear about other projects
as well.
Many of these projects have funding from U.S.
Government sources which
adds an interesting geopolitical twist to
not only the cyber-conflict but to the role
of circumvention technologies.
More broadly, what is happening now in Iran
offers a clear example of
the new generation of controls that are being
exercised in cyberspace.
As the domain becomes more heavily contested
and is seen as a critical
vector for the exercise of power, rather than
first generation controls as exemplified by
China's Great Firewall,
we're seeing instead the emergence of what
we call second and
third generation methods that are more subtle,
flexible.
Sometimes offensive in nature, designed to
go beyond mere denial to
shape and limit the room for expression online.
So in my talk today, I'm going to offer on
overview of these trends in
cyberspace controls.
And I'm going to be doing it through the lens
of the OpenNet
Initiative, which is one of the projects that
I helped found and still help to oversee and
run.
I do this not because the ONI is a world leader
in documenting these
methods, but because the new forms of control
I describe present a
challenge to the ONI's own methods.
And the challenges to the ONI's methods that
these new controls present
are analogous to the challenges that I think
are -- present themselves
to the circumvention technology community.
And so I talk a bit the end of my presentation
about those challenges
for circumvention that I hope we'll pick up
today in this workshop.
Let me begin with description of the ONI.
When it was formed it was a three-university
collaboration with four
principle investigators and founders.
My colleague Rafal Rohozinski, who is the
host of this event here, at
the time was at the University of Cambridge.
He started something called the Advanced Network
Research Group.
And it was one of the original founding partners.
Also, involved are my colleagues from the
Berkman Center at Harvard
University, John Paul Free and Jonathan Zittrain.
And at one time, there was a kind of functional
division of labor here.
The Citizen Lab was the primary base for a
lot of the technical
development and the technical analysis and
the development of tools.
Harvard was the place where a lot of the organization
takes place and a
lot of the open source information gathering
was implemented.
And Cambridge, under Rafal's direction, was
responsible for a lot of the deep field research
and managing our network of field researchers
that I'll talk about.
In fact, the project has its beginnings even
earlier with some student
projects.
And one of the -- at that time, a student
Nart Villeneuve, who is here
joining us today, along with Ben Edelman at
Harvard University were
both working in similar areas.
Trying to undertake technical interrogation
of the Internet to find out
what content was being blocked by countries
around the world.
That was the problem that we were attempting
to address.
Now this functional division of labor has
changed over time.
Partners have come and go.
As it stands right now, Cambridge -- Rafal
has moved from Cambridge,
really rests on the two universities at Toronto
and Harvard.
But we have a variety of partners and projects
that have in one way or another either spun
out or have some connection or network relationship
to the OpenNet Initiative.
And that includes our sister project, the
Information Warfare Monitor,
the SecDev group, SecDev Cyber, which Rafal
runs and Greg Walton and
Nart worked for.
Psiphon is a circumvention tool.
Again it has its origins with Michelle La
Veck and Nart, is now a private company.
And I'd also point out OpenNet Asia which
is a regional network of about 16 organizations
across Asia.
As well as E-PIN, the Eurasian i-Policy Information
Network, which involves networks throughout
Central Asia.
So the OpenNet Initiative, although it rests
with these two
universities, is really a broad umbrella of
projects and organizations
that span really all regions of the globe.
Now the mission of the ONI is to document
patterns of Internet
censorship worldwide.
And when we started the project, the problem
we were confronting was
this issue of --
There'd be reports of web sites being inaccessible
or filtered or
blocked or censored.
And there was no way to confirm or verify
whether this was the case or
not.
And we wanted to bring some, some rigor to
this project.
To bring some empirical methodology to it
so that we could provide a independent authoritative
basis from which, say, advocacy groups who
are interested in this area could point to.
And I think we've done a fairly good job of
that.
And at the core of the OpenNet Initiative
is a methodology, that I
think is quite unique for the social sciences.
And it informs, I think, all of the projects
that we do at the Citizen
Lab.
We call it a fusion methodology, which is
a combination of technical
interrogation methods, which I'll talk about
a bit more in some detail.
And these often get the most attention when
people are looking at the
OpenNet Initiative.
The combination of technical interrogation
and field research that is
undertaken by actual human beings who live
in the countries that we're
interested in.
And although the technical side gets a lot
of the glory, I think the
most valuable component of the methodology
of the OpenNet Initiative is
the fact that we have this capacity of people
who live within the
countries that we're investigating,
who target our technical tests, help us understand
the context, the social, the political context
within which our investigations are undertaken.
Help us understand what is happening in their
countries, so that we can
get a better idea of what's going on.
As I mentioned with OpenNet Asia, we have
15 partner organizations
that are part of our wide umbrella.
And the data from both of these sources is
combined using
multi-disciplinary analysis.
We're not primarily technical people.
Although there are some very bright technical
people who are part of
the OpenNet Initiative.
We're social scientists.
We're lawyers.
We're sociologists, political scientists.
People who understand the context of the countries
that we're
investigating.
And I think that's really a critical dimension
of what we do.
In terms of the technical side, on one level
it's really quite simple.
What we've done is we've created a -- a set
of software tools that are
deployed in countries that are under investigation
that give us a
snapshot of what's being filtered, not comprehensively.
We don't have access to large data sets like
what was described by the
Google engineers.
So instead we have to be much more targeted
and selective.
And what we've done is we've created a database
that we've maintained
over the years now, where we have baskets
of content.
And there're two large baskets, meta baskets
you might say, of content.
We call globalist and localist.
And when -- within each of these baskets are
thousands of categorized
URLs, keywords, and domains.
In the global list are domains that we test
in all countries.
This is a -- provides us with a basis of comparison
of content that is
being targeted for filtering.
And it's, you know, human rights organizations,
news sites,
pornography.
There's probably about 20 different categories
of content in the global basket.
In the local baskets are content URLs and
domains and keywords that are
unique to each country.
And these are usually in local languages.
They're either based on reports that we get
about filtering that might
be taking place in a country,
we want to confirm whether that's happening.
Or they're put together by our in-field researchers
who understand
that, you know, this website of this particular
opposition group might
be targeted at any one time.
So, the -- what happens is people who are
in the country are travel or
travelling to the country take our software.
It connects back to databases in Toronto.
And it essentially automates the process of
checking for accessibility
to this content.
It does so both locally and then with the
control server in Toronto.
And we do a basic comparison.
We run some further tests to try to identify
at what level the content
is being filtered, what methods are being
used.
Is it a IP block?
Keyword block?
URL path?
A domain that's being filtered?
Is there some commercial filtering product
being employed?
So we run a variety of metrics that allows
us to get some sense of the
techniques that are employed in filtering
around the world.
Now, I think we have a pretty impressive list.
I'm very proud of what we've been able to
accomplish over the last
several years.
We started out by doing country reports.
So focussing on individual countries one at
a time.
China, Saudi Arabia, and Iran and so on.
We've issued several Internet watch reports
and bulletins and
advisories.
Around 2006, we were fortunate to receive
funding from the MacArthur
Foundation, which allowed us to ramp up a
global comparative survey.
Beginning first with the around 56 countries,
all simultaneously done.
And in the last round, we tested in close
to 70 countries.
We've produced two books now on the topic
that report on these findings
and provide some theoretical overviews and
analytical overviews of what
we found beginning with Access Denied.
And then more recently Access Controlled,
which some of you may have
heard of.
That was the subject of controversy at the
recent Internet Governance Forum.
I can talk more about that.
The Chinese delegation did not like that image
appearing outside of the
room in which we were announcing the book,
because it contained a
reference to the Great Firewall of China.
Now what about the broad findings here?
I'm just going to quickly summarize some of
the main trends without
getting into details before getting into these
new generation of
controls.
So based on what the ONI has been looking
at, based on what our
methodology is oriented to find here is what
I can tell you.
First of all, I would say that even though
we haven't been testing the
same number of countries over time,
and we haven't been using exactly the same
data -- we're not looking for the same thing
each time.
I can say confidently that Internet censorship
is growing worldwide.
When we started out there were really only
a handful of countries
engaged in Internet censorship.
Now there're in the latest round, there are
close to 40 that have some
content filtering going on within their borders.
The vast majority of content that is targeted
for filtering is local
language content.
So that may be contrary to conventional wisdom.
You'd think that within a country they're
more concerned about people
accessing foreign news and foreign information.
Although that happens, disproportionately
most countries target the
content that matters closest to home.
So they focus on local language content.
In China, it's Chinese content.
In Iran, it's Farsi content.
And that makes sense.
You want to limit and contain what citizens
in your borders have access
to that matters most to your local political
situation.
Most of the countries that engage in Internet
censorship do so with
very little transparency and accountability.
And we heard some of -- some about some of
that this morning with respect to China.
But it's, I would say the majority of the
countries to don't do with a large degree
of accountability.
Some countries yield block pages that say
the content is forbidden.
That's the most transparency you'll get.
Most of them do not talk openly about it.
They don't discuss what type of content they
target for filtering.
So we're doing a lot of unearthing of what
goes on beneath the surface.
I would say also that this lack of transparency
and accountability is
multiplied by the fact
that many countries use commercial filtering
products to do the job of censorship.
And the reason that I say this multiplies
the lack of accountability
and transparency is because the block lists
that are used to do the
filtering are considered trade secret.
They're considered proprietary.
So researchers like us at the ONI, we can't
examine those block lists
to see whether there's any filtering errors
or category errors that may
prejudice the filtering that's going on.
And in our research, we've been able to identify
the use of products
like Fortinet, Websense, SmartFilter.
Most of these are California-based companies
that are used to
essentially violate basic human rights in
places like Burma, Yemen,
Iran, and Tunisia.
Of course, this has now become a subject of
considerable public policy
debate in the United States about whether
these companies should be
permitted to provide services to countries
that do that sort of thing.
And we're of course following that closely.
Some other basic findings.
You know, there're about 7 or 8 countries
that we would categorize as
pervasive filters of Internet content.
By that we mean they filter in every category
of content that we
measure for.
So it's political content, conflict, Internet
tools, cultural content.
There are about seven of them.
And then there are a lot more countries that
selectively filter one content category, say
pornography for example.
Or maybe it's a country like South Korea that
blocks a lot of content
related to North Korea.
Some other things we found.
Mission creep, we call it.
This is where countries once they've put in
place Internet filtering
for whatever reason, even if it's to deal
with something that seems
maybe plausible and legitimate.
Maybe some form of hate speech or extremism
or whatever or pornography,
once the tools are in place, it's very tempting
to use them to deal
with other troubling public policy issues.
So for example, in Pakistan where Shasad here
will be speaking about
the Pakistan situation later today, filtering
that started off by
ostensibly blocking imagery containing cartoons
that was offensive, has
now broadened to include independence and
insurgency movements like the
Balochistan liberation movement.
A lot of countries target, instead of content,
the services and
platforms that are used by people, especially
web 2.0-type platforms.
And there's a lot of collateral and upstream
filtering.
Rafal is actually the one who coined the term
upstream filtering.
And for many years was prodding people at
the ONI.
This is an issue we need to look at more closely.
And now, of course, we realize that he was
very farsighted about that
because there have been several incidents
where countries are getting
their service from other countries upstream
where filtering affects
them.
A good example is the blocking of YouTube
in Turkey that was described
earlier today, affect users in Georgia.
Because the Georgian ISPs got their service
from a telecom company in Turkey.
And that's common in a number of other countries
as well.
As Bob said you with go to our site.
You can get these maps that are clickable,
and take you into deep dives
for each of the countries.
And we categorized them in different ways
to give you kind of slices of
which countries block what content.
You'll see that the number of countries increases
quite substantially
when you look at social content.
And that's because there really is now a driving
force coming from the
advanced liberal industrialized countries,
Western countries, whatever
you want to call them,
who are now implementing filtering for pornography
or hate speech in Europe, Canada, North America,
Australia and so on.
And this is, I believe, kind of creating a
normative terrain here that
is making it acceptable to implement content
filtering or impose
requirements on Internet service providers
which gives legitimacy to other countries
who are doing it for quite different reasons,
which needs to be discussed.
Now I mentioned that the next generation controls
that we see emerging,
that I'm going to talk about, have presented
a challenge to the ONI.
And I believe really the ONI is in the middle
of a kind of --
for those of who follow philosophy of science,
Thomas Kuhn has this notion of anomalies and
how these anomalies can create challenges
to accepted paradigms.
And you have paradigmatic revolutions take
place in the time of
anomalies.
And I feel we're very much in the ONI in one
of these stages.
And over the last several years, and again,
I would single out Rafal
actually, has been really critical in pointing
out those areas where
there are gaps in how we go about doing what
we do.
For example, blocking events that were occurring
outside of the ONI
testing window that we were missing.
When we test with the ONI, we aim to test
on every major ISP in a
country, at least two rounds, for every phase
of testing but it's really only a snapshot.
It's like going in a taking a picture and
then leaving, right?
Meanwhile, a major demonstration or election
would occur, the ONI
testing is not going on.
We don't know what's happening during that
period.
We're also, of course, missing a lot of contextual
factors that may
reflect our concentration on technical interrogation.
This is the something I advise the engineers
at Google, who are looking
into reasons why blocking is occurring and
so on.
Just reiterating what was said earlier that
contextual factors are very
important to understand that -- that can inculcate
a climate of
self-censorship,
where intimidation factors, and threats, and
informal requests, and those sorts of things
that happen that aren't always picked up.
And a number of other things as well.
The big event for me personally, and for many
of us, was in -- when we
were monitoring for Internet censorship in
Kyrgyzstan in 2005.
And Kyrgyzstan a country at that time, very
little if any, Internet
filtering to speak of.
But we happened to be testing in that country
during the time of
elections.
And opposition newspapers, their web sites
came under denial of service
attacks.
And the owners of those -- the operators of
those web sites came to us,
because they knew we were testing in the country,
and they said can you
help us?
You know, we're being blasted.
And can you analyze what's going on?
So we actually had their content hosted in
Toronto and analyzed the
traffic.
And in fact engaged in some conversation with
the people responsible
for the attack.
And it turned out that the Kyrgyese authorities
had contracted out to a
Ukrainian hacker to blast these opposition
newspaper web sites offline
during the time of demonstrations.
And this is something that Rafal actually
coined the term "just in
time" filtering, which is a great way of getting
at this idea that
information only has value at certain periods
of time.
And that's -- when it has its highest value,
when it's most critical,
that's when you need to bring it down.
Not necessarily all the time making it inaccessible
to everyone, just
at certain periods of time.
And I think this is really what happened in
Kyrgyzstan was kind of a
window into what is becoming now the norm
worldwide.
Where we're seeing these next generation controls
-- and I'll just run
through a bunch of these, and these are the
type of things that we're
seeing as now defining what you might call
the Internet censorship
situation globally.
So we have, for example, legal and normative
measures where slander and
libel laws are being used to intimidate producers
of content.
Threaten them with some kind of sanction or
point to such laws to have
bloggers or posters remove information, or
the hosting platforms
undertake that action on behalf of the authorities.
So it's not uncommon in some countries for
authorities to either go
directly or maybe informally through visits
by security services to
ISPs, to social networking platforms, and
say if you don't remove this,
there're going to be certain consequences
for you.
Very similar to what we discussed earlier
today.
We see the Kyrgyzstan case being multiplied
and duplicated in other
parts of the world, where it's not uncommon
for web sites to at critical times to be taken
down by criminal organizations or DDoS attacks
that are contracted out by somebody.
And this is the interesting thing, and I think
why it makes it so
attractive as a tool of shaping cyberspace,
is that there's plausible
deniability for those involved.
If you contract out to a criminal organization
to undertake a DDoS
attack you can say, hey, it's not us.
There's no paper trail.
It's not something we're going to admit.
The Internet's always a problem in this country.
It's down.
It's got some technical issue.
And of course we see this same thing going
on in all these cases right
now as we speak in Iran.
And that's where I think things like "just
in time" blocking is going
to become more common, in fact.
Where around elections public demonstrations,
we'll see critical
sources of information being removed.
Computer network attacks now are becoming
standard parts of many
states' information warfare doctrines.
And, of course, we saw real instances of that
being deployed Estonia
and Georgia.
And even more nefarious, I would say, is the
example -- patriotic
hacking, where citizens either acting on their
own or maybe encouraged
by governments undertake acts, undertake information
attacks.
Again allow for the state to have some kind
of plausible deniability.
And then lastly, and this is really I think,
the front where at the
Citizen Lab and with our various projects
and partners we're spending
most of our time right now, is with targeted
malware attacks and
targeted surveillance.
Of course, many of you will heard of the GhostNet
Report.
Prior to that we had been examining many other
cases where this sort of
thing is going on, where human rights organizations
are being targeted
with malware.
That's more than just, you know, viruses floating
in the ether.
These are deliberate attacks that are meant
to pry inside the
information of organizations who are adversarial.
And again this is becoming something that
is part of many states'
apparatus now.
And I think this is where we really need to
change the kind of context
for this conversation.
Whereas in the past it was about Internet
censorship on the one hand,
freedom of expression on the other.
I think we live now in a completely different
context where there is a
active cyber arms race going on.
And I think that can't be underestimated.
Many countries around the world have now come
out.
Whether in the last year like the Obama administration,
or years before that, saying yes this is what
we want to now have as part of our arsenal,
the ability to
undertake computer networks attacks, targeted
malware attacks.
And these are affecting all spheres of cyberspace.
You know, you have attacks on the physical
infrastructure, critical
infrastructure, like say what happened Estonia
or Georgia.
Attacks that target the code sphere like malware
and spam and so on.
This context is creating pressures in the
regulatory sphere.
New laws are being introduced that download
a lot of policing and
monitoring to Internet service providers that
are really changing their
relationship to the network that we think
of as cyberspace.
And lastly, the idea sphere.
And by that I mean the way in which now psychological
operations are
playing into standard cyber warfare doctrine.
And what that will entail for not just cyberspace
but I would say for
what we're discussing here today.
I think you can look at all spheres here in
the context of cyber
warfare and talk about what the impact will
be on the circumvention
technology projects that are discussed here.
I'll just give one example.
There is, under the regulatory sphere now,
a very real concern with
attribution and anonymity.
And you hear calls for the end of anonymity
online.
And that sort of pressure is I think one example
of what we'll see more
of.
And again, I just reiterate this is not just
the developing world
phenomenon.
It's something that we may have first confronted
with the ONI in
Kyrgyzstan,
but it's something now that's happening among
the great powers at the highest level that
is really creating a kind of culture shift
internationally.
Now what are the wider implications of these
next generation controls?
Well, first I think, you know, speaking kind
of selfishly here.
I think there is a real challenge for the
OpenNet Initiative.
We designed that project with first generation
controls in mind.
We built a whole methodological apparatus
around the idea of monitoring
and documenting and analyzing what you might
call "Chinese-style
filtering."
You know, passive blocks that are programmed
into routers that we can
come in with our tools and identify and verify.
Whereas the new controls that are emerging
are much more subtle and
flexible and operating "just in time."
And that really, I think, creates a challenge
for us as a monitoring
organization that we're going to have to confront.
I think that there is a very real sense in
which the -- the adversaries
-- the way in which we used to think of those
who were responsible for
Internet censorship, you know, it's the Chinese.
It's the Iranians.
It's the Saudi Arabians -- are now being replaced
by a much more
complex, diffuse environment.
And a lot of the controls are being downloaded
to private actors.
And that makes again this whole area much
more complex.
When Facebook or Twitter or one of these platforms
engages in acts that
are essentially censorship acts,
it's much more challenging to monitor, to
confront and deal with than it is when it
is a government where it's a clearly identifiable
adversary, even if they're not transparent
about it.
It's much more murky.
I think that as I said circumvention technologies
are going to be drawn
into this battle.
That there's a new geopolitical contest taking
place within cyberspace
that's going to affect all of the projects
that are assembled here.
And I think that's one challenge that I would
put before everyone.
Lastly, I think one of the things I've been
advocating for --
for better or for worse lately --
is arms control in cyberspace.
And without getting into the nuances of the
debate there, I've always
thought that it's important as part of an
agenda to promote arms
control in cyberspace.
To think about promoting, also, a broad social
movement around the idea
of protecting the Internet,
protecting cyberspace as a form for free expression
and access to information.
To me that is one of the pillars of an arms
control agenda for
cyberspace.
And it's in that light, that I see the value
of the projects that are
being put forward here.
So I'll end it there.
And thank you very much for the opportunity,
and I look forward to the
next couple of days.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
>>[INAUDIBLE SPEAKER]
>>[INAUDIBLE QUESTION]
DR. RON DEIBERT: Yep, sure. The question was
about Australia, and the
proposals there for a national filtering system.
And we've been engaging in monitoring in Australia
just like in a lot
of other countries.
This is a proposal is being discussed as far
as I know, anyway.
But it's emblematic of the type of discussion
that's happening in a lot
of other advanced, industrialized countries.
I think the difference with Australia was
a bit more extreme of a
proposal than what's happening say in Canada.
In Canada, the model is for private companies
have entered into a
voluntary arrangement.
It's not that a law has been imposed upon
them.
Where they're blocking access to a list of
sites containing images and
texts and so on of child abuse.
Child pornography.
The list of information is provided by a kind
of civic organization, a
monitoring organization, Cybertip.
And I guess, you know, first of all, let me
say about this discussion
as a whole, it's always a very difficult one
to enter into.
Because right away it's -- it's one of those
areas of conversation
where you hesitate to sound like a defender
of the content in question.
Because I think, you know, this is one case
where certainly I believe
this content is objectionable.
It's already illegal to circulate and produce
in many countries.
And I think that's great.
So the question is not about whether this
content should be circulating
or not, at least in my mind.
It's about how to deal with it.
And I think in the case of Canada, you have
a very bad solution.
And the case of Australia is probably even
worse.
In the case of Canada, private companies are
undertaking this mission
with the help of this Cybertip.
Researchers can't examine the block list.
We're not allowed to check whether there are
any errors.
There's no government oversight.
There's no way for citizens who are concerned
about whether their
content is included mistakenly in this category,
is a problem.
So to me there are a lot of issues with this.
Actually, Nart Villeneuve in the back of the
room here, did a chapter
for Access Control on this topic.
And Nart, if you -- do you want to add anything
to that?
[PAUSE]
>>Is this working?
Well, I think the main problem is the tension
between filtering which
is sort of easy.
And take down which is much more difficult.
So, what happens is there are organizations
all over the world that act
in this same way that Cybertip does, like
the Internet Watch Foundation
in the UK.
They accept tips from the public, and then
they check to make sure that
those URLs --
at least I think they're URLs, and hopefully
not domain names or IP addresses --
contain illegal content, give them to the
ISPs.
The ISPs block them with whatever method they
choose.
Then what happens is they don't circulate
that information amongst
other tip agencies.
So when Canadian authorities find bad sites
in the UK, we just block
them.
We don't phone them up and say, "Hey, you
have these bad sites over
there.
Maybe you should do something about it."
So Canada actually blocks content that's hosted
in the U.S., despite
the fact that we have two law enforcement
--
like joint law enforcement agencies that are
targeting -- that are supposed to work on
the issue of images of child abuse online.
And a network of operators like Cybertip,
they're supposed to exchange
information.
So someone's dropping the ball somewhere.
The result is that people block a minute amount
of content to prevent
-- and they clearly state it's to prevent
-- accidental access to
images of child abuse.
So it has nothing to do with trying to get
that content offline,
figuring out who's circulating that and posting
that content.
It's just a very kind of -- we fill in the
bullet point on the
presentation to say we're doing something
about this issue kind of solution.
DR. RON DEIBERT: Thanks, Nart.
>>[INAUDIBLE QUESTION]
DR. RON DEIBERT: Geez, that's a question for
all the Google engineers
here.
I have no idea.
Interesting, I suppose.
I mean to me the findings of the ONI's research
in that area --
For those who didn't hear the question is
about the blocking disproportionately of local
language content --
could machine translation help?
And you know as I said I think it's a interesting
question.
But -- for me the what we've done there I
think is interesting to a
certain extent.
To me, it's -- it's all of the other ways
in which controls are being
exercised now that are becoming much more
important.
And our research doesn't really get at.
And that's troubling to me and a few others.
And we need to really refine the way we think
about doing what we do.
Although, it's still interesting as a snapshot
that a lot of countries
target local language content, sure.
>>[INAUDIBLE QUESTION]
DR. RON DEIBERT: Well, sure.
I mean, beginning in this country, there was
-- one of the most
interesting things about the Cyber Security
Review was that the world's
worse-kept secret about information operations
and computer network
attacks was being openly discussed for the
first time.
So it's not that it wasn't going on before.
It's now being legitimized.
I think that was a very important threshold
that had been crossed.
Actually, I was among a group of people that
commented on the cyber
security announcement that Obama made.
And that was the one thing that struck -- one
of the things that struck
me was this fact.
And once that happens, of course, it creates
a typical spiral in
international relations where other countries
feel compelled to follow
suit and so on.
I think right now, you know, the reason that
the idea of cyber arms
control is dismissed as so naive --
for one reason anyway, is because the momentum
is so much in the other direction right now.
So many countries are seeing this as an area
where they need to catch
up, first of all.
And also an area that yields very valuable
information.
As I said, most of our research now is in
this domain of targeted
surveillance, targeted espionage, malware
and so on.
And looking at the type of research that's
done by Greg Walton and Nart
and the people who are working at the Citizen
Lab on this topic.
It's remarkable to me how much you can gain
access to because there is
such a insecure underbelly to the Internet.
All of these devices that are connected to
it that are highly insecure
yet contain sensitive information that can
be collected and used for
whatever purposes.
I think is now such an attractive thing for
intelligence, for military
that it's creating this dynamic of an arms
race.
And I think it's affecting what we used to
call in the past Internet
censorship, which we thought of at least I
did, well, this is something
that governments do.
They program content into routers somewhere,
and you're not able to
access it.
Where this is -- there's a whole bigger fish
floating out there.
A much bigger set of problems that we need
to put this in the context
of -- including circumvention technologies,
I would say.
>>[INAUDIBLE QUESTION]
DR. RON DEIBERT: Well, well, the first thing
I'd do is I'd direct them
to my very capable people who I work with
who know more about what
they'd like to get access to.
So people like Nart and Greg and Rafal.
But for me I -- you know, listening to that
conversation this morning
about the data that Google has latent access
to,
let's say, that tells us a lot about some
of these outages and blockages.
To me, that would be interesting to make that
data, of course, open to
researchers and research organizations like
the OpenNet Initiative.
Would be very valuable for us.
And likewise, you know, in turn we could do
that with the OpenNet
Initiative.
Find ways to make our data more accessible
to organizations like
Google, that would be one.
I think there are areas that many people today
here, again, very
capable people on the circumvention side would
suggest things.
I'd be interested to hear more about what
that is.
Thanks a lot.